当你跟你的妹妹感情有多深，
在这个时候要帮忙的话，
要适当的帮，
而不是踮起脚尖帮，
不是牺牲自己的人生去帮，
不是把自己的未来全砸进去去帮，
你一定要听得进去这个话，
不然的话，
你到最后跟你妹妹会反目成仇的，
千万不要在这种人生大事上那么糊涂，
去给他什么承诺，
帮他一起拉扯孩子，
一个月给他多少生活费，
孩子跟着你过，
千万不要我妹夫她出窃他七二姐家40多克的房间，
3月5号上午的时候帽子出去上门抓人了，
5号的晚上他二姐那边出去了，
谅解书也被举报出来了，
我现在想问一下我妹她离婚和不离婚，
想听听您这边的意见，
有孩子吗？
有孩子他们是一八年结婚，
有两个儿子，
一个是七周岁上小学，
一年级一个是5周岁上幼儿园出发，
结婚后呢，
我认为是发生了两件大的事情，
第一件事情呢，
就是我妹妹的婆婆和公公吵架嘛，
婆婆说的那个就从ICU的时候呢，
公公就不拿钱，
是我妹把她以前拿出来救她婆婆的，
我从旁观者的角度的话，
我感觉她婆婆也是我妹妹也不落后，
那个拿钱救她命啊，
也没什么感觉。
第二件事情就是去年2。
后年买房，
因为我大侄子要上一年级嘛，
是在县城买房子上学的，
买房子这件事情呢，
我们不是由我妹牵头的，
我妹夫就跟在后面看，
他父母看房的也不拒，
钱呢，
也一分不掏，
那房子的总价是60万，
首付万是18万，
我借给我妹7了，
我爸是借4万，
我妹夫的亲大姐是借4万，
他们拿3万，
贷款是42万，
每个月要还3000块钱的房贷。
现在我想问一下呢，
这个情况我们如果想离婚的话，
两个孩子能争取到吗？
还有财产的一部分，
那如果是不离婚的话，
您这边什么建意呢？
首先得看你妹是干什么工作的，
他的经济条件怎么样，
他将来如果说分开，
他想要两个孩子抚养权，
假设一切如他所愿，
他养得起吗？
养得起，
我跟我妹说的就是呢，
如果他想离婚的话，
我自己听到说要两个孩子，
我心里面都心想，
我说我和你一起抚养两个孩子，
你有见样过，
我是单身，
那你将来要成家吗？
我不成家，
你今年多大？
我是九三年的，
你93年你才30出头，
你说这个话为时尚早，
而且你现在给出这个承诺，
说你跟他一起抚养这个事儿的话，
千万不要做出这样的承诺，
你一旦给出这样的承诺，
就是一笔债，
不管你跟你的妹妹感情有。
多生在这个时候要帮忙的话，
要适当的帮，
而不是踮起脚尖帮，
不是牺牲自己的人生去帮，
不是把自己的未来全砸进去去帮，
你一定要听得进去这个话，
不然的话，
你到最后跟你妹妹会反目成仇的，
千万不要在这种人生大事上那么糊涂，
去给他什么承诺，
帮他一起拉扯孩子，
一个月给他多少生活费，
孩子跟着你过，
千万不要。
我也知道31个人的人生是很重要的一个责任，
但是我也很心疼我妹，
这话再扯回来哈，
因为发生这个事情了之后呢，
我妹夫呢，
也不主动和我妹谈这件事情，
感觉好像没事发生一下，
我妹六号的晚上就主动找他谈了嘛，
说让你父母拿出十万块钱出来，
就帮我们外债还一还嘛，
不会说再有那么大的压力，
我们趋向于我妹妹为什么要出大姐的黄金呢？
压力太大了，
父母一分支持都没有，
又养两个孩子，
又有房贷，
又有人情往来，
但是呢，
我妹夫给出的回应就是呢，
说他想离开那种离开，
我感觉是威胁我妹，
我妹夫的父母呢，
和我妹谈，
每年呢给一点钱给我妹，
再到我父母那边去保证，
感觉事情又回到了明面，
我们是突然我妹的父母他们手里面有钱，
但是呢，
他们一分钱不包，
又把孩子逼到这种地步上。
姑娘，
你今天花了300块钱来问我，
那我某种程度上要对得起你给我花的这300块钱。
我们俩之间是一个信任和被信任的关系，
我接下来要讲的话对于你的人生至关重要。
首先第一点，
你的妹妹的公公婆婆之间矛盾这么深，
一方要么另一方都不愿意出钱，
第二点，
她的婆婆是属于那种遇到问题了之后自己就想着要一了百了，
且你的妹妹用她的彩礼钱把她救回来了之后，
对你的妹妹也不冷不热，
也不念你妹妹的好，
那就说明什么问题？
说明你妹妹的公公婆婆不是什么好人，
你希望于他们对儿孙承担责任，
这种想法是愚蠢的，
你寄希望于这种不负责任，
对自己的伴侣见死不救，
对救了自己的人没有感恩之心的这老两口，
你希望他们对儿孙负责任，
你说你这想法得多可笑。
是的，
两个孩子生下来，
从怀孕到生产到上学，
他们公公婆婆一分钱都没掏，
包括家里面的人情往来啊，
最基本的从真的是医疗保险啊，
都是我妹掏的钱。
你说的对，
你知道你妹妹之所以付出了还不落好，
其实某种程度上是因为你们过度对他的保护，
过度对她的支持，
过度给她依赖，
过度给他一个觉得他。
靠着原生家庭，
我能靠着我姐，
我能靠着我爸，
我能靠着我妈妈，
她才敢过度的去帮衬她的婆婆，
或者说帮衬她的公公，
这跟你们也有直接的关系，
因为有你这样的姐姐，
什么事儿都想着给她兜底，
所以他才那么糊涂，
所以他才那么蠢，
所以他才一而再再而三的把你们拉入绝境。
你这个事情啊，
不要插手，
不要过度承诺，
在你的这个年纪，
30出头，
过度承诺等于不负责任，
因为你做不到，
我把话撂这儿，
你做不到。
当有一天你发现你的侄子并没有那么感恩你的时候，
你就会停止对他们的经济支持，
你就会变得薄情，
你就会变得无意，
为什么？
我告诉你，
善良的人不会变坏，
但善良的人总有一天会变得无情，
会变得无情。
你如果说一味的去支持你的妹妹，
一味的养着你两个侄子的话，
你总有一天会变得无情，
你总有一天会兑现不了你的承诺，
那抛开我这部分不说的话，
我妹现在如果他选择离婚的话，
哎呦，
我不离婚，
你们这边是什么建议呢？
他不离婚，
他自己赚的钱，
你们给他贴补一点儿吃的喝的，
给侄子买点牛奶，
买点苹果，
买点衣服，
这些都没有问题，
他日子能过得下去，
他想离婚，
这是他的人生决定，
你不要撺掇他离婚，
你不要说有我呢，
你别怕，
千万不要说这样的话，
到最后你会跟你的妹妹都会反目成仇的，
他到时候会怪你。
要不是你当初承诺我，
我怎么会离，
要不因为你，
我人生怎么那么悲惨，
你一定要听进去啊，
妹妹，
我真的是掏心掏肺的跟你讲，
人性就是这样，
没有例外。
是的，
人性是经不起口误的，
所以你不要掺和，
你不要掺和，
他问你该不该离，
你说这是你的人生决定，
我们也不替他做决定，
当一点后盾吧，
感觉如果是真离婚的话，
这个两个孩子我自己都该你割舍不下的那个这么说啊，
你要一个月工资有8000块钱，
你说你每个月想起来，
你给他们买点水果，
买点冰棍儿，
给孩子们买点鞋子，
买点袜子，
买点衣服，
买点裤子，
花个八百一千的那没问题，
但你不能说我一个月就挣5000块钱，
完了之后我3500块钱都要拿给我的妹妹去交学费，
拿给我的侄子侄女去花，
我跟你说，
你到最后你一定会心生怨言，
因为你有你的人生，
你有你的未来，
你要说你年入200万，
你说我一个月给他5000块钱当什么呢？
我就当捐款，
那可以，
那或许你不会有心生怨言，
因为你捐给陌生人你也愿意啊，
但如果说你自己没有这个本事，
你没到那个经济条件的话，
我跟你说，
千万别把自己逼成这样一个到最后薄情寡义的人，
抛开我这部分不说的话，
你只单纯自我认为，
建议是什么呢？
公公婆婆不是什么好鸟，
老公不是什么靠谱的角色，
从现在开始就是实用主义。
实用主义是什么意思？
就别惦记，
别惦记公公婆婆会给钱，
别惦记老公会上进，
她现在能用吗？
能帮我看孩子吗？
能给孩子做饭吗？
能给孩子洗衣服吗？
能打扫卫生吗？
能好接着用，
这样的话我才能解放出去，
挣钱去。
实用主义还能用吗？
还有实用价值吗？
有的话接着用，
没有的话那没办法呀，
他想争取两个孩子的抚养权的话，
他自己得有收入啊，
得向法官去证明我能养活这两孩子，
我才能争取两个孩子的抚养权呀，
这是其一。
其二，
对方如果确实因为盗窃定罪了，
争取孩子抚养权的话，
那女方就占优势了呀，
肯定是定罪的，
定罪的话，
女方有很大的优势，
是有可能争取到两个孩子抚养权的，
我懂你的意思，
如果说离婚了，
我妹妹想要两个孩子，
就可以以这个方面来打，
那如果不要孩子，
那可能一家一个，
有两个孩子怎么也得一家一个，
那如果不离婚呢？
以前都说婚内协定约定书怎么写的，
他们有什么财产呢？
其实就是一个房子，
还有一辆车，
房子在谁的名下？
房子是婚后买的嘛，
是在两个人的名下，
如果要约定这个房子归你的妹妹的话，
还得去做一个公证才行，
去公证处如果只是写一个约定书的话，
还意有效力是吗？
如果只是写了一个约定书，
但是这个房子又没有实际的完全过户到你妹妹一个人头上的话。
是有争议的呀，
要么就是说完全过户到你妹妹的头上了，
且写了一个约定书了，
这个也可以，
他的那些外债呢，
比如说他们买房子借的那些钱，
我们的约定书上可以需要你，
这些都属于男方吗？
那得看当时借这个钱是怎么借的，
如果是两口子一起去借的，
那这是共同的债务，
即便是你约定这个债务归男方一个人来偿还，
也只是在两口子之间管用，
对于人家借钱给你们的人是不管用的，
人家借钱给你们的人，
当时如果说有证据证明是两口子一起去管亲戚借的，
一起去管银行借的，
一起去管谁借的的话，
那这个就是共同的债务，
你懂我你的意思了，
我没担心我妹夫他后面还会发生这种事情的话，
有没有说什么在婚内约定书上可以交你这些的，
我的理解是这样啊，
如果你的妹夫他是因为犯罪给别人造成的损失的话，
这个不叫夫妻共同的债务，
这是他个人的债务，
那如果他用于共同生活上来了，
那叫追赃了，
那得退赃，
那肯定得退出来，
肯定得吐出来，
你必须有义务要这样去做是吗？
那得退赃啊，
退赔呀，
我等下那定说只能对房子有一定的约束力，
其他外债啊什么，
或包括到后面如果产生犯罪啊，
这些赃款什么的，
其实对我妹也没有什么其他的保障。
如果你妹妹参与使。
从赃款那退赃不是天经地义的事儿吗？
是的，
其他还有什么问题啊？
其他没有了，
谢谢你，
我知道我今天跟你讲这个话，
你此时此刻你听不进去，
你会觉得我低估了你们之间的亲情，
我不了解你们之间的姐妹感情，
我不了解你们一家人有多团结。
我觉得你现在还年轻，
你才30出头，
你的人生有很多属于你的重要的人际关系还没有出现，
属于你的重要的亲缘关系还没有出现。
你这个时候可能是一心想着帮你的妹妹，
一心想着帮着她拉扯两个孩子，
但总有一天你自己会有你的人生。
我妹是不赞成我这样的，
因为我妹说她不想把我拉入离开，
她说如果说我妹夫还能将就用，
就把孩子一起拉啊。
现在想看男方的态度是什么，
因为他们还是想得到父母的一些支持吧，
因为确实养两个孩子太困难了，
如果说是因为我妹她是做黄金这个事情，
实际原因也是他们，
我感觉生活压力太大了，
让父母有能力支持的时候，
在我们这种农村人就感觉儿子嘛，
那肯定是要帮衬一把的，
我们这种思想就是想让他父母帮衬一下，
他父母确实也不会听你们的指挥，
也不会听你们的安排，
所以这事儿就别想了，
我懂意的意思，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜。
助者恶意这个事儿，
它不光存在于朋友之间、
同学之间、
工作关系之间，
它也存在于亲缘关系之间。
受助者恶意他是有心理学的基础的，
或者说有人性基础的，
人性的基础就是谁都不希望一直成为弱者，
谁都不喜欢自己成为那个被别人怜悯和帮助，
一直非得对别人感恩戴德的那个角色，
有多少人？
你自己也是一种心理，
你也不愿意承认自己是那个弱者，
一直要需要靠别人的帮衬，
你才能活着，
你才能过日子，
心里也不舒服，
所以会产生受助者恶意。
记得点赞关注哦。